welcome back to CBS morning's later
today the house select committee
investigating the January 6 assault on
the capitol plans to release its full
report and follows a vote on Monday a
big one really a historic vote
recommending that the justice department
pursue possible criminal charges against
former president Donald Trump that kind
of vote had never happened before the
four suggested charges include inciting
an Insurrection the committee's
investigation lasted nearly 18 months it
collected about 1200 interviews and more
than one million documents and
California Democrat Adam Schiff was a
member of that committee and the
congressman joins us now Congressman
thank you for being here great to be
with you I've heard you say that you
believe there is enough publicly
available evidence to charge the former
president given that being the case in
your view do you think he will be
charged by the doj
that's a very good question I think it
depends on whether the justice
department lives up to what the Attorney
General committed at the beginning of
the investigation and that is that
Donald Trump would be treated like any
other American that there was one
standard of the rule of law
um and that they just would follow the
evidence wherever it leads well it's led
to Donald Trump
so what for under what circumstances
then what calculations would the doj the
special counsel decide not to indict
well under circumstances in which the
department departs from that policy and
decides you know we need a higher burden
of proof for a former president and in
this case either we're not willing to
take the risk or we decide that it would
be too divisive to it would look too
political to prosecute the former
president uh the just Department took
the position while he was in office that
you can't indict a sitting president now
I think that's a flawed interpretation
of the Constitution but if you take that
position then you later decide that even
when a president leaves office you still
can't prosecute them for crimes because
it'll be to convert controversial then
they're basically immune they're immune
well so how damaging in your view would
it be to our effort to heal and restore
a sense of normalcy in the aftermath of
January 6. how important is it that they
go through under a normal set of
circumstances with an indictment that
you think is deserved
if the if the justice department
concludes that the evidence is there
that they can prove that he committed
crimes Beyond reasonable doubt he should
be indicted
um the the founding fathers would have
never accepted the idea that a president
is somehow unprosecutable that they can
commit any crime and you can't hold them
accountable the precedent it would set
given the the laundry list of of likely
offenses this President committed yeah
um would be too dangerous because any
subsequent president could decide I
could do whatever I want do you believe
they're moving too slowly I believe they
have moved way too slowly they they move
quickly when it came to the foot
soldiers the people that broke into the
capitol assaulted police officers but
for the higher ups and for other lines
of effort to overturn the election they
have taken way too isn't it good to be
deliberate and even meticulous and and
how they approach this it is given the
stakes yeah absolutely but but we're
almost two years from the events of that
day that makes sense that's a long time
how difficult a decision was this for
you all to reach this conclusion unless
we saw all the evidence we hear uh
unprecedented and historic I think it's
important for the people to know the
time and care that was put in this was
this a difficult decision because Donald
Trump says political Witch Hunt there's
there's no there there it's all about
politics it was certainly a somber
decision to make not one we made lightly
but at the end of the day it wasn't
difficult and that there wasn't really
difference of opinion among the members
there was a strong consensus that the
evidence supports criminal referrals we
believe that with respect to
inciting an Insurrection and conspiracy
to defraud and obstruction of an
official proceeding conspiracy to lie
that Donald Trump committed all these
offenses and as the Congress itself was
the victim of some of them our democracy
all of them that we had an obligation to
report what we knew to the justice
department what are we going to learn
from this full report scheduled to be
released later today that we don't
already know a lot now it's a lot that
fills in some of the missing pieces and
with the report we're going to begin
rolling out transcripts so you'll see
why we don't find Tony arnato the Deputy
Chief of Staff very credible when he
says essentially that he was unaware of
the propensity for violence that day uh
you'll hear a lot more of Cassie
Hutchinson's testimony and other key
Witnesses and I guarantee there'll be
some very interesting new information in
the report and and even more so in the
transcripts that we release could you
show us a bit of it now what could give
us a little bit of a tease more uh well
you'll see why we're concerned that that
Witnesses may have been interfered with
or an attempt to influence them uh and
uh and I think you'll hear you know much
more uh very interesting but granular
detail about these multiple lines of
effort to overturn the election can we
talk about President
zielinski coming in today to make his
case in front of Congress and the
American people there it seems to be
some concern about Ukraine fatigue now
about spending the money that is being
sent to Ukraine where do you stand on
that do you think at what point does the
U.S say I'm so sorry but there's really
nothing more we can do or do you think
we need to stay in for the Long Haul and
it's been a long haul for her for
however long it takes I think we need to
support Ukraine for however long it
takes if the Ukrainian people can fight
and not fatigue then we should be able
to remain steadfast with them
they're fighting for their own democracy
their own sovereignty but they're
fighting for the principle that powerful
Nations shouldn't be able to Simply
redraw the map using military force and
and I think democracy more broadly is
really at risk in this conflict and what
do you say to people say yeah but we
have problems in this country that
aren't being addressed that that could
use some financial help what do you say
to that that is absolutely true uh there
are dramatic unmet needs at home and we
ought to meet them but at the same time
if we allow Russia to invade an ally
it's going to invite more Nations maybe
it invites China to invade Taiwan it's
going to be destabilizing yeah dangerous
and that will ultimately be a danger in
the United States and we could spend a
lot more trying to defend ourselves if
this precedent is set Congressman I want
to talk about you for a moment here uh
the Republicans as they take control of
2023 are widely expected to remove you
from your committee position on the
Intel Community Dianne Feinstein also
questions about why the show run into
2024 that would open up a historic seat
there in the state of California for
Senate do you plan to run for Senate for
that seat uh well first let me address
the the committee issue this is
something Kim McCarthy is threatening to
do to try to get the votes of the
Marjorie Taylor greens of the world and
while I have a particular interest in
whether I remain chair or ranking member
of Intel the bigger concern for me
frankly is if McCarthy becomes speaker
and the next presidential election is
close and they lose he'll overturn the
results and to me that's far more
serious an issue than what happens to my
committees in terms of Senate uh if the
Senator Senator Feinstein who admire
greatly decides to retire I'm giving a
very serious consideration getting a lot
of encouragement back home do you think
he's going to become speaker Kevin
McCarthy I think if I had to guess that
he becomes speaker but that he doesn't
remain speaker
um the easy decision is the first one uh
the hard decision is when you actually
have to decide policy and there why
wouldn't he remain speaker uh I think
one of the kind of hidden Stories the
midterms is that a lot of these Q Anon
uh right-wing crazy Republicans won
Republican primaries and deeply red
districts we didn't hear about them that
much because they weren't in competitive
general elections they're coming the the
the crazy caucus in the Republican party
in Congress is going to grow at the same
time there are a few moderates and
they're going to be clashing the first
decision Kevin McCarthy makes is going
to alienate some of them yeah and he's
let me just say this they have the same
narrow majority we did and he's no Nancy
Pelosi congressmanship thank you so much
we appreciate you